hey Greg what's up oh nothing we're
gonna be novel
do we want to go out tonight we've got a
lot to think about here not really we
never do anything fun anymore
yeah but after this week of crap I kind
of feel like we don't like people
anymore let alone going out pretending
like everything's okay really true no
but the idea of meeting new people is
terrifying why are you lying to me keep
keep in mind I'm you you're me were we
and we like people just fine yeah but
it's nice and quiet here and we'd save
money by not buying overpriced booze and
we could overanalyze that time that we
wave to that stranger who is actually
waving to that person behind us six
years ago you and I both know we're just
gonna end up getting drunk Google in the
cast of Seinfeld mumble and sublime
lyrics how could anything be more cozy
than this moment on this couch why do
you want to mess with perfection because
we might miss out on an epic night of
insanity here at the very least laugh
with our friends or throw up in an
alleyway girls does that really sound so
bad what would I wear anything you wear
is fine as long as it's not the pajama
pants with the hole in the crotch that
you've worn for the last four days what
if we go out and it sucks and we leave
distracting me from me does sound pretty
cool I haven't had an on gchat
conversation in weeks it let's party yes
you